welcome to another morning show I have a
new guest with me a fellow dancer who's
joining for the day how can I help what
do you got it's been said that you DJ to
inspire and that sort of really
triggered something in my mind in terms
of where I want to go with my launching
a a new album that I'm producing my
moment and I would love to know how you
how that would translate to music
without being too obvious or cheesy cuz
you know how cheesy music can get when
you're like oh this is an inspirational
song now okay okay so that kind of thing
so listen great art makes people feel
whether you're singing or dancing or
anything right you watching the video
like great art makes you feel something
where where a lot of times artists fall
down is they don't explain the art
enough so there's a painting on the wall
that like the person poured their life
into yeah but then I don't somebody
coming from it who doesn't understand
that style doesn't know how to feel and
looking at it okay waning the story the
backstory behind it to say choose in
songs you have a little bit of an
advantage in that you get the use vocals
and yeah of course like your song should
have a message absolutely yes and and
the tone of the song has a message it
makes you feel something like the faster
way to change your state is to put on
music absolutely one represent you're
down and you put on most people do the
opposite they're down they put on sad
songs and then they stay down yeah if
you down you put on your favorite like
pop and song you're gonna get yeah I
live some fear it's totally in the
creation of the songs you already get
the pick the vibe that you want people
to have right well you've already picked
your songs yeah I would say like they
are pretty obviously meant to be
inspirational like it's not the way I
don't go okay I'm writing this fictional
song now let's go but it's just the way
they come out so that's what I'm going
with but I just wanted to like in terms
of like you've done a ton of things
where you are involved in big groups and
you somehow and you just said you came
back from LA and you ended up sharing
your message with a ton of people after
the other that was your thing so like
you know for my album want to say it's
my album launch party or some sort of
that I'm having I wanted to also not
only just be on a stage and perform but
also have a way to give back
maybe charity wise or maybe some I don't
know have some sort of angle that would
tie in more than just oh she's just
another singer artist whatever from wood
are aware of her it you mean yeah so the
way that I usually go through it and you
can you can hack it or use a different
version but I start with the one word so
it's like your most important core value
is the one word so what what do you
value more than anything else so for me
it's believed yeah right and so when you
figure out what that is then you start
just thinking okay how do I bring more
like if it was believed for example for
you then how do i how do I make people
believe through the music that I put on
how do I believe in themselves through
the album cover then I'm gonna create
okay right how do i if I'm gonna do a
launch party how can I make them feel
believe just by walking in the door okay
how are they greeted by the person at
the front what's gonna be on the walls
right all of that stuff is more
expression it's more art it's all art
okay so if we you who's talented and
like you got your fingers and lots of
different yes artistic expression that's
that's a fun challenge so if the theme
of I would say man empowerment is
probably my number one all right now
great so empowerment greats all the
songs are about empowerment and the
lyrics are about empowerment and it's
not gonna be some dark like Halloween
unfortunately no right no it's great
some power is awesome now how how can I
feel empowered just by looking at your
cover right so that I look it up and
like mend I feel empowered just I need
to I want to dive deeper because I feel
empowered just looking at at this album
cover now maybe you maybe have the
skills to do it yourself or maybe you
need to work with a designer who's gonna
mm-hmm come up with it but but even
having that mindset going in so cookie I
want I'm gonna be on the cover but I
need to I need an empowered like I want
people to feel empowering by me with my
picture on the front yeah so if again if
you work on the photographer to take
your your picture right just give them
that work as well or that direction
hey you know I might pose like Wonder
Woman like here they're like let's go to
the top to some filthy nerd or whatever
right so that you are co-creating
because if if somebody is saying to you
I need an empowerment song mm-hmm and
you know a little bit about their story
you can then craft a song or I need
empowerment dance you can create a dance
that help people feel empowered right
that's your art right
but photography may not be your art and
Albert and design may not be your art
and the venue space may not be your art
yeah so giving clear direction to the
artists who are gonna be helping you and
creating all that it'll helpful yeah any
good so I can you're all about
empowerment awesome and so if it's
empowerment that's that's great if you
can express how you want people to feel
then you co-create with the artist
you're gonna be working with to then get
hopefully the end result so throw the
entire process like that becomes the
filter now for everything right so from
if you're gonna have a launch party
great like what venue is a venue that
means something that that is about like
if it's about women empowerment is it a
woman owned venue that you're gonna tell
her story yeah nightclubs are
male-dominated it yeah they're one
that's run by a woman that you're gonna
do it in a place yeah the story is it
gonna be all women's stuff you know
ouncer I don't think of all I do not
think like this but but the whole
experience but now it's only because you
said empowerment right so yeah is it an
all-woman stuff is it is it like a
female bouncer I've seen women at the
front I would be amazing I would love
that yeah I think so I haven't seen a
woman bouncer right yeah but there's got
to be we're definitely must be right
it's like it's an all woman crew and
then then right yeah they need to be
like is there is there no dude our
uniform you want people to wear that
represents empowerment you know like are
you happy you have a logo for the for
you or a logo for that so working on it
so then great so when you're working
with your local designer like that's a
government yeah yeah what represents
empowerment to you is it a cape is it a
shield is it is it a flower is it a you
know
than shoe is it a not thought of that I
wrote I honestly had not thought of that
but all that kind of stuff then even if
you just look at pictures and say I feel
I feel empowerment like when I see if I
stick the power might I think of like um
like I think it Beyonce stuff is very
empowering yeah the UN one oh I was here
yeah yeah I love the song yeah every
song so that kind of stuff like if you
even just watch through that like
there's there's this woman like black
woman powerful maybe in front of the UN
like why the yeah yeah why not some feel
somewhere no yeah you want to making a
statement
yep right yeah amazing so that becomes a
filter for everything right even even
through conversation a few like how can
you leave every conversation with
somebody that they feel empowered ah
right yeah alright so that's like my
like lifestyle now not just like
everything at render like yeah gimmick
exactly but then then then it reduces
the fear of like how you're seeing I
only see it as this yeah because it's
just who you are it is yeah and that's
that's the shift so in every meeting
with somebody and every if you're
recording with the sound engineer or
you're meeting with a local designer
whoever you deal with your students in
your classes you're performing in front
of an audience they should feel
empowered in every interaction with you
just because it's who you are it's good
so do you think one of the things that I
always brag on people is when they end
the conversation like we're leaving and
they say take it easy if they never see
take it easy okay don't tell don't tell
don't tell me yeah I don't want to take
it easy yeah right I want to live life
yeah go work but like life right yeah so
even something like that like how do you
grieve like when you came in give me a
huge hug cry it's like vibrate yeah yeah
sorry so how do you keep people and how
do you then leave a conversation so that
they feel empowered under them so it
becomes the filter for everything
whenever you don't know what to do okay
what would an empowered version of this
look like okay and then that becomes a
guidance and direction you give and
yeah so if I go to your Instagram you're
gonna feel empowered you know what's
your one what's your what's your bio
your you got a couple lines in there
yeah I feel empowered what are the
pictures you're putting up isn't you
feel empowered to them and it's a
constant evolution you know it's not
like it's a one static this thing
forever yeah but but how you express
empowerment you're still gonna care
about empowerment and speaking of
evolution actually this is a slight
departure from where I'm normally right
for my whole career like I said I've
done musical theater yeah and so most
people know me as a singer dancer actor
they don't know me as a recording artist
I'll per say do you think there is a way
or it doesn't have to be a definite like
jumping off from and evolving notice to
the world or is that to instagrammy
like no no I care more about the
marriage in the wedding so like I'm not
I'm actually not a huge like launch
party person I okay like statement I
just I'd become yeah yeah like this new
show that I've just decided to start
doing yeah you didn't like build up
build up build up several months and
months you know like okay it's coming
this is gonna launch it's kind of it
yeah so shoot okay so I don't most of
his also because I don't really care
about how people see me right I just am
and if you love it awesome and if you
don't awesome
yeah so it's not about I don't care
about how I'm positioned or how like if
you're feeling the burn of people's eyes
on you scene but what did she doing like
you're not a singer you're a dancer okay
stay in your lane he's feeling the
burning of that then you have to go off
and do that thing yeah right yeah ever
ever afraid of judgement then you have
to go off and nothing just yeah a
judgement yeah I mean no but my heart is
like totally totally in it to life you
just feel like even coming to meet you
and talk about it was like I was like
bowling up with tears I'm so excited to
meet you and like I was like to take
another step towards it you know tenido
yeah yeah so I wouldn't I wouldn't care
so much about you
it's it could be good marketing to say
hey I've always been I would lean on the
authenticity
I've always been seen
as a as a dancer a performing artist
I've always loved to sing I've been for
whatever reason hesitant to come out and
and sing because I've been seen a
certain way and I have a certain
reputation but now it's a time yeah you
know that was a time and that ties in so
well with empowerment yeah and like for
everybody watching like now's your time
to yeah you through you doing the thing
that you're afraid to do it becomes the
permission for other people to do the
thing that they're afraid to do just the
whole thing of empowerment Wow so I
wouldn't lean in to say I'm a badass and
hey I've always been a great singer
right I'd known the other side was like
I was scared to do this yeah but it's
time like yeah I need to do this with
any guys love it or not right and then
that won't give permission to their
people to come off and do it okay so
thank you yeah also if you want to know
what I think and what other successful
entrepreneurs think about building
confidence check out my new 250 for
confident series where every day for the
next two hundred fifty four days for
free I will send you a 30 second a five
minute video in the morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below
if you want to be more confident you
need to surround yourself with things
that make you feel confident realizing
that any big endeavor is the collection
of a lot of small steps that came before
if you're doing work that you loved
you're more likely to follow through
you're more likely to do it because it
doesn't feel like work because you love
doing it the most important work ever if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to learn how to make it as a
musician I highly recommend the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I want to tell you the
most important piece of information that
applies not only to your musical career
but your entire life
you